good afternoon
over the past five years america
has fought its way back from the worst
recession since the great depression
we passed historic reforms to prevent
another crisis
and to protect consumers over the past
three and a half years
our businesses have created 7.5
million new jobs our housing market is
rebounding
manufacturing is growing the auto
industry has come roaring back
and since i took office we've cut the
deficit
in half now i think everybody
understands we've still got a lot of
work to do to rebuild
the middle class but we've made progress
and we shouldn't do anything to threaten
that progress
for these hard-won gains have
made a difference to millions of
americans and in part we can
thank the extraordinary grit and
resilience to the american people
in part we can thank the dynamism of our
businesses
but a lot of it also has to do with the
choices we've made as a nation to create
more jobs and more growth
and one of the most important
contributors to this whole process
has been the federal reserve under the
strong leadership of ben bernanke
for nearly eight years ben has led the
fed through some of the most
daunting economic challenges of our
lifetime
for some time now he's made it clear
that he intends to finish his service as
chairman
at the end of his term which is this
january
so today i just want to take a minute to
pay tribute
to ben for his extraordinary service but
i also want to announce my choice for
the next chair
of the federal reserve one of the
nation's foremost economists
and policy makers current vice chairman
janet yellen you know after i became
president
i was proud to nominate ben for a second
term
and while the fed is and must always be
independent
uh i want you to know ben i'm personally
very grateful to you
uh for being such a strong partner in
helping america recover from recession
perhaps it's no surprise as the son of a
pharmacist and a schoolteacher that
ben bernanke is the epitome of calm and
against the volatility of global markets
he's been a voice
of wisdom and a steady hand
at the same time when faced with
potential global economic meltdown he
has displayed tremendous courage and
creativity
he took bold action that was needed to
avert another depression
helping us stop the free falls stabilize
financial markets
shore up our banks get credit flowing
again
and all this has made a profound
difference in the lives of millions of
americans
a lot of people aren't necessarily sure
what the chairman of the federal reserve
does but
thanks to this man to the left of me
more families are able to afford their
own home more small businesses are able
to get loans
to expand and hire workers more folks
can pay their mortgages and their car
loans
it's meant more growth and more jobs
and i'd add that with his commitment to
greater transparency and clarity
uh he's also allowed us to better
understand the work of the fed
you know ben has led a new era of
fed speak and been a little more clear
about how the system works and that is
good for our democracy
and i have to tell you as i travel
around the world the job of
the fed chair uh is is not just
uh you know our top uh
monetary policy maker
the world looks to the american fed
chair for leadership and guidance
and the degree to which ben is admired
and respected and
the degree to which you know central
bankers
all across the world look to him for
sound advice and smart policymaking is
remarkable
he has truly been a stabilizing force
not just for our country but for the
entire world
and i could not be more grateful for his
extraordinary service so ben to you
and uh your wife anna and your children
joel and alyssa
i want to thank you for your outstanding
service thank you so much
now as i've said uh the decision on who
will succeed ben is one of the most
important
economic decisions that i'll make as
president one of the most important
appointments that any president can make
because the
chair of the fed is one of the most
important policy makers in the world and
the next chair will help guide
our economy after i've left office i've
considered
a lot of factors foremost among them is
an understanding of the fed's dual
mandate
sound monetary policy to make sure that
we keep inflation in check
but also increasing employment and
creating jobs
which remains our most important
economic challenge right now
and i found these qualities in janet
yellen
she is a proven leader and she's tough
not just because she's from brooklyn
janet is exceptionally well qualified
for this role
she's served in leadership positions at
the fed for more than a decade
as vice chair for the past three years
she's been exemplary
and a driving force of policies to help
boost our economic recovery
you know janet is renowned for her good
judgment she sounded the alarm early
about
the housing bubble about excesses in the
financial sector
and about the risks of a major recession
she doesn't have a crystal ball but what
she does have is a keen understanding
about how markets and the economy work
not just in theory but also in the real
world and she calls it like she sees it
janet also knows how to build consensus
she listens to competing views
and brings people together around a
common goal and as one of her admirers
says she's the kind of person
who makes everybody around her better
not surprisingly she is held in high
esteem by colleagues across the country
and around the world who look to the
united states as i said
and the fed for leadership janet is
committed to both sides
of the fed's dual mandate and she
understands the necessity of a stable
financial system
where we move ahead with the reforms
that we've begun
to protect consumers to ensure that no
institution is too big to fail
and to make sure the taxpayers are never
again held left uh holding the bag
because of the mistakes
of the reckless few and at the
same time she's committed to increasing
employment and she understands
the human costs when americans can't
find a job
she said before these are not just
statistics to me the toll is simply
terrible on the mental and physical
health of workers
on their marriages on their children so
janet understands this and america's
workers and their families will have a
champion in janet yellen so janet i
thank you for taking on this new
assignment uh
and given the urgent economic challenges
facing our nation i urge
the senate to confirm janet without
delay i am absolutely confident that she
will be an exceptional chair of the
federal reserve
i should add that she will be the first
woman to lead the fed in its 100-year
history
and i know a lot of americans men and
women thank you for
not only your example and your
excellence but also being a role model
for a lot of folks out there
so it's been said that janet found love
at the federal reserve literally
this is where she this is where she met
her husband george a celebrated
economist in his own right
uh and their son robert is an economist
as well so you can imagine
the conversation around the dinner table
might be a little different than
than ours
in fact i've been told their idea of a
great family vacation
uh is the beach with a suitcase full of
economics books
uh but this is a family affair we thank
george and robert for their support as
janet
begins this journey again i want to
thank ben bernanke for
the outstanding work that he's done and
obviously he will continue to
help uh keep our economy moving forward
uh during the remainder of his tenure
here so we'll probably have
occasion for additional goodbyes and
i know that janet is very much counting
on him to give
some good advice to her as as she uh
moves into the chairman's spot
but with this i'd like to give janet a
chance to say a few words
thank you mr president i'm honored
and humbled by the faith that you've
placed in me
if confirmed by the senate i pledge to
do my utmost to keep that
trust and meet the great
responsibilities that congress has
entrusted to the federal reserve
to promote maximum employment stable
prices
and a strong and stable financial system
i'd also like to thank my spouse george
and my son robert i couldn't imagine
taking on this new challenge without
their love and support
the past six years have been tumultuous
for the economy
and challenging for many americans
well i think we all agree mr president
that more
needs to be done to strengthen the
recovery
particularly for those hardest hit by
the great recession
we have made progress the economy is
stronger
and the financial system sounder as you
said mr president
considerable credit for that goes to
chairman bernanke
for his wise courageous and skillful
leadership
it has been my privilege to serve with
him
and learn from him
while we have made progress we have
father to go
the mandate of the federal reserve is to
serve all the american people
and too many americans still can't find
a job
and worry how they'll pay their bills
and provide for their families
the federal reserve can help if it does
its job effectively
we can help ensure that everyone has the
opportunity
to work hard and build a better life
we can ensure that inflation remains in
check
and doesn't undermine the benefits of a
growing economy
we can and must safeguard the financial
system
the fed has powerful tools to influence
the economy in the financial system
but i believe its greatest strength
rests in its capacity to approach
important decisions with expertise
and objectivity to vigorously debate
diverse views and then to unite behind
its response
the fed's effectiveness depends on the
commitment
ingenuity and integrity of the fed staff
and my fellow policy makers they
serve america with great dedication
mr president thank you for giving me
this opportunity
to continue serving the federal reserve
and carrying out its important work on
behalf of the american people
you